yves corbassières peintre
existentialiste est un spécialiste de la
peinture à l'huile sur la toile et
parfois sur la tôle quelle que soit
l'époque les modèles et les vitesses
corbassières n'a jamais caché sa passion
pour les voitures et les belles
carrosseries pour les besoins d'un
concours organisé par notre confrère
l'auto-journal 5 battre était confronté
pour décorer 5 ford fiesta
parmi eux corbassières qui avait choisi
une manière rapide
[Musique]
c'est très original préférons appeler
tous épouvantés mois
trouvez que peintre qui avait ça non
vous connaissez ce peintre là n'ont pas
fait pour vous
non mais ça me fait penser un peu
ces faits qu'albert pour les porsche 3
vous avez ça
ils dégradent ils sont tous je lis sur
l'autre celle là non ça vous aimez pas
non pour ce peintre c'est minable
un schéma dit ça
je complète passée
vous n'avez pas non j'aime pardon parce
que c'est moi le plein oui je vais sans
doute séparé outre à vous saviez pas non
je savais pas
[Musique]
vous savez comment c'est fait quelqu'un
est posée dessus
pour l'aplatir la couche de peinture
corbassières dans ses oeuvres
mon chapeau et maintenant je vais faire
un événement avec une femme pinceaux
parce que un pinceau dans une massa
pense
et là je vais diriger mon modèle de
faire une trajectoire tragique traînée
de peinture sur la voiture je
présenterai
sans ce championnat
maintenant je rentre dans le top 3
tragique de l'action donc une
procuration à être longue et je vais
mettre la peinture sur le sujet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
offert un retournement
[Musique]
le pensait
toujours rien
[Musique]
et les y sont
ces travaux nous parlant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chose d'une autre en boîte les noob ils
y sont voilà juste c'est de savoir ça
aurait été commencées n'est rien
[Musique]
sur le choix du modèle core bastia s'est
trompé le pinceau humaniser méritait à
lui seul ou à elle seule le premier prix
quant à la pauvre voiture il devra se
contenter de la cinquième et dernière
place
[Musique]